for me I mean it's over I'm done the
character of Samantha will live forever
I mean she's your best friend she's your
she's someone who will tell you the
truth I love her so much but she lives
in a time and a place and I honor that a
Sex in the City shocker Samantha's back
I never thought I'd see this day you and
me both hell just froze over yep despite
two decades of fighting E.T has new
details about Kim Cattrall's top secret
return the Cameo shot for an end of
season Cliffhanger oven just like that
was filmed back in March in a town car
in a queen's New York parking garage are
you kidding me it was all so Hush Hush
Kim's name never even appeared on a call
sheet oh and Kim was solo she did not
film with any of her co-stars which is
interesting considering her
long-standing tension with her castmates
which some say started over 20 years ago
when they were reportedly bickering over
salaries during the final season of Sex
in the City I don't see them the common
ground that we had was the series and
the series is over there will be one
friend absent Samantha um
no I mean that wasn't something that we
ever talked about
I think that Kim has made it really
clear that she's done and we've heard
her what was your reaction to Kim
Cattrall telling Piers Morgan that you
were never friends I think she could
have been nicer I found it very
upsetting that's not the way I recall
our experience so why did Kim change her
mind well it could be an incredible
Payday the three stars of the max series
SJP Cynthia Nixon and Kristen Davis
reportedly made over one million dollars
per episode for the first season of the
10 episode series
18 hours after E.T confirmed Samantha's
return the season two trailer dropped we
are all blissfully unaware when our
lives
are about to change the new season
starts June 22nd and although there's no
mention of Samantha there is another fan
favorite Aiden sitting here with you is
like 10 years just
and speaking of reunions for Kim's new
scene which could set up Samantha for a
full-on return in season three Kim
reportedly worked with legendary Sex in
the City costume designer Patricia field
how it has influenced me with color and
splash and you know she always says
you're that sexy one another big star
returning to a franchise Dwayne Johnson
he just announced his return for another
fast and furious movie yes it is true
Hobbs is back it's a big reversal for
the star who insisted he was done with
the series after clashing with Vin
Diesel on set in 2016.
often times just like in life you have
different fundamental philosophies on
how you do things I
always fight us having our differences
me and Ben we've been like brothers for
years The Rock will also be a producer
on the film which is still Untitled wait
to see what happens when Dante and hops
Collide in true Hub speak Daddy's gotta
go to work
all right I love you guys and Ops is
back
foreign